ano Puduru 4 f 9
Amami Oshima s Foam Charhan Roots Pipe 2 pou dou dou Up
Stick Parts Phillips phone The
name is Akiho Anoha
. The food culture that our predecessors have created is the food culture
that we want to win.  Hey, it
has a very long history, it doesn't need water, it
grows very persistently.
I think you'll hear that the poison often enters your body
when you eat it.  This is what has been piled up,
so
-called 6 p-Shinohara's way of
doing it.
Field process for men Station End Line Poise x
Type
[Music]
I've put only one piece in this now, but it's ridiculous.
There
are many castellas, sweets are coming out, and
rice cakes are coming out.
[Music]
Eh
eme
tee In
this village, the sand-iron miti and Shinto are fully open.
I'll start putting it in. If you
bring it in, take one shot and take all the red
ones, then divide it into a meat cram school and prepare it in the sun.
[Music
] Put it like this for
1 week to 10 days.  There is a corner at the beginning from the time you cut it while watching the situation until the end of the human department in the school yard
.
Tanihara: It would have been a lottery trip if you could move it. I'm sorry.
I have
a house because I have a house. Amami people are
n't the same. It
's a special merit award that connects the colors of the islanders
.
Everyone can give away the food made by the sweet people. The big
cold is to
those who take it. Give instructions.
When this is gone to some extent, replenish only the pot and eat 50.  It's a child who remembers the top of the
lever. I
lived a life,
but since this shape is poisonous, eating it is
the wisdom of that life, isn't it
? Above all, it served the islanders.
I think it's a plant that should be
complimented and given.
That leads to my purposeful life
[music]